leggo has many exciting ranges including  Star Wars Harry Potter and Indiana Jones  now we're proud to announce a new range  one of the most exciting and  action-packed ever lego philosophy  inside the box you'll find everything  you need to get your exclusive  philosophy world up and running your  exclusive philosopher comes with no  accessories whatsoever their main  purpose is to be made to sit in the  corner and think they do nothing  they make no money they can't operate  machinery they couldn't drive something  like this or fly that but they do have a  purpose they take our thoughts which  often line a tangled mess and they order  them into beautiful manageable chunks so  that we can hopefully understand  ourselves and the difficulties facing us  a little better think of them as the  cleaners and Rangers of our minds every  Lego collection and every society should  have a people of these philosophers  somewhere in the background ready to  clean up our thoughts  you